it's just
you've got mustard on your
at the mustard there right there
you've just turned 50 years old you
found out you have stage three lung
cancer even though you've never smoked
in best case scenario with chemo you
might live for a couple more years you
take a look around and realize that life
has passed you by your day job doesn't
earn you the respect you think you
deserve or enough money to pay your
bills and your second job is even worse
and in a desperate attempt to leave
something behind for your family after
you inevitably succumb to your cancer
you turn to your lifelong passion for
chemistry and become a drug kingpin as
absurd as that last part sounds it turns
out to be the perfect setup for one of
the greatest TV Pilots of all time
Jesse you asked me
if I was in the meth business or the
money business
neither
I'm in the Empire business
as an introduction to something
completely new every pilot episode for a
television series has a lot of work to
do it has to deliver the show's premise
introduce the main characters and build
out their world in many cases before it
gets made the script needs to convince
Studio Executives that it can draw in an
audience and get them to invest in
producing a whole season when it gets in
front of viewers it needs to grab their
attention and leave them wanting more
the Breaking Bad pilot had even more
work to do because it needed to
introduce a main character who comes off
pathetic enough to find him in the
situation I mentioned at the beginning
but at the same time competent enough to
pull off the whole Kingpin part a
character whose story we could buy into
and a guy we could root for even if he
started to do some questionable things
with hindsight it's easy to see how the
transformation of Walter White turned
out to be such a compelling story but
the idea was a tough sell in 2007. the
president of AMC at the time Charlie
Collier explained the situation the TV
Guide like this you're asking really
smart people to part with tens of
millions of dollars prior to spending
many millions more in marketing it you
had to explain that you wanted to bet on
a series where a chemistry teacher who
almost won the Nobel Prize Cooks meth
with a former student it was very much
placing bets that all look easy in the
rear view but were really big at the
time and not obvious Vince Gilligan had
his work cut out for him this was his
first showrunner gig but he wasn't new
to the television industry he spent
seven years as a writer on the wildly
popular and influential X-Files and even
had a co-creator credit for its mostly
forgettable spin-off series The Lone
Gunman he's been vocal about how much he
learned while working under the X-Files
Creator Chris Carter with an emphasis on
how he learned to be a producer and a
showrunner and to empower the people he
worked with to give them as much of an
investment in the show as possible in
2017 he told the Huffington Post if you
expect your crew people the folks around
you to have the same investment in the
show as you do if they feel the same
ownership as you do that can lead to
great things and by all reports he
Incorporated this into his approach to
running a TV show and the positive
effect it's had is easy to see his time
at the X-Files directly impacted
breaking bad's development in several
other ways first and foremost it's where
he crossed paths with Brian Cranston who
was the guest star in the season six
episode drive that Gilligan wrote
Cranston made an impression to the
extent that he fought to give him the
role of Walter White even when the
studio Executives were concerned because
the world knew him as the affable father
on Malcolm in the Middle having that
earlier performance as an example of his
range was enough to land him the role
and while it's fun to imagine when a
Breaking Bad would have been like with
some of the other actors they considered
for the role such as Matthew Broderick
or John Cusack Cranston delivered the
performance of a lifetime creating one
of the most compelling characters in TV
history there really is no Breaking Bad
without that performance and that's
probably never more apparent than it is
in the pilot episode several other
Breaking Bad cast members appeared on
the X-Files including Aaron Paul who
would play his ex-student and future
partner in crime Jesse Pinkman Dean
Norris who played his hyper masculine
brother-in-law Hank and Michael Sheamus
Wiles who played his boss at the DEA
Raymond Cruz who was Unforgettable as
tuko Danny Trejo who would lose his head
as Tortuga and Michael Bowen who played
Walt's final foe Uncle Jack beyond the
performances the Breaking Bad pilot
excels in both its writing and its
cinematography and both of those things
were influenced by Gilligan's early
career The X-Files was a show that was
ahead of the curve and the shift towards
cinematic TV and HD TVs becoming
ubiquitous created the perfect
environment for for the Breaking Bad
crew to take this to the next level
I am awake
what
from its opening sequence it's clear
that Breaking Bad intends to push the
boundaries on what could be done in a
medium that had been limited Michael
slovis who left his own mark on the
series after he became the Director of
Photography in season two described how
things came together for the pilot in a
2013 interview with Forbes a young
filmmaker wanted to shoot in the style
of spaghetti westerns he wanted it wide
and he was going to do that no matter
what was going on in the world of
Hardware however it just so happened
that during the last seven years
widescreen televisions became affordable
and HD became the norm now people could
see what we were doing and we didn't
have to tell stories and the old style
of close-up close-up the inclusion of
those wide shots helped to define the
overall visual language of the series
The backdrop the world where the story
takes place is treated as its own
character Albuquerque in the desert that
surrounds it are so much a part of
Breaking Bad style it's almost hard to
believe that it wasn't Gilligan's first
choice and that he didn't have any
connection to the city before he decided
to film there based on a meeting he had
with the real de agent that lived there
he had set the story in Riverside
California when he wrote the original
pilot script in one of the many
roadblocks they ran into that turned out
to be blessings in Disguise it turned
out they couldn't afford to shoot in
California the producers learned of a
tax credit that was being offered in New
Mexico and tried to push to take
advantage of that because it was one of
the only places where they could afford
to make it years later Gilligan would
tell TV Guide how important this turned
out to be New Mexico is far better than
any other state could have been for
breaking bad because it allowed our show
to become a contemporary Western which
is not what I was thinking at the time
the look of Albuquerque with the amazing
endless guys with the big puffy cumulus
clouds in the Sandia Mountains to the
east just the geography of the area the
landscape was so cinematic that it
actually changed my thinking and changed
the way we shot the show it's somewhat
surprising that Gilligan only had two
previous directing credits for X-Files
episodes considering how good the pilot
actually is part of that can be credited
to his decision to hire his friend John
told to be the Director of Photography
toll had won best cinematography Oscars
in back-to-back years for Legends of the
Fallen Braveheart and his attaching
himself to the project in his first job
in TV helped to ease concerns about
Gilligan's lack of experience been Vince
took the opportunity and ran with it and
established some of the techniques that
would go on to Define this Show's visual
style beyond that focus on wide shots
the two that stand out are the object
POV and the process heavy Montage toward
the end of the episode we watched Walt
look into the dryer with the camera
positioned inside it's strange and it's
cool and the fact that he's drawing the
money brings some pretty obvious things
to mind first you think about dirty
money and then the fact that drug money
needs to be laundered in order to spend
it something that Walt hasn't yet
planned for and that reinforces just how
out of his element he is but the shot
itself and the many others like it we
see throughout the series serves a
purpose directors use shots from the
character's point of view to heighten
the viewer's connection to what the
character is experiencing and at times
make it feel as though we could
influence what's happening Breaking Bad
flips this on its head and shows us the
characters from the point of view of
inanimate objects disconnecting us from
the character's experience provides us
with the sense that we can't do anything
about what is happening to them the
pilot also delivers the series first
Montage as Walt and Jesse work through
their first cook generally montages are
a great way to condense the passing of
time but they can also explain where
characters are emotionally as we watch
what they're doing on screen this not
only helps us understand the characters
without a lot of extra dialogue but it
also trains us to pay attention to the
details in other scenes since the show
is setting out to do something that
isn't common on TV showing us a
character change over the long Arc of
the story it needs to teach us to pay
attention to things that might be
crucial to understand where the story is
going this first Montage expresses that
even though Walt may have let himself go
and resigned himself to living a life he
doesn't find satisfying his passion and
determination return while he cooks
you're a goddamn artist
this this is Arts Mr White
actually it's just basic chemistry but
thank you Jesse I'm glad it's acceptable
at one point during the filming of the
pilot Vince Gilligan came down with the
flu and got so sick he had to leave the
set this gave Jon toll the opportunity
to go out and shoot additional footage
of New Mexico that they were able to use
throughout the first season to immerse
viewers in that setting one of the most
memorable shots of the first episode
while it's khakis flying through the air
was filmed while the director was
recovering in his hotel room it was
another potential problem that turned
out to work in the Pilot's favor by
giving it one of the most memorable
opening sequences of all time in the
first 23 seconds we go from peaceful
shots of the desert landscape to an RV
barreling down a dirt road with the
floating pants serving as a bridge
connecting the two together going back
to re-watch the pilot it's almost hard
to remember how effective this opening
was because by now you know who Walter
White is but the first time you see it
you have no idea what's happening this
is elevated by the choice to start the
episode episode in medius rays which is
Latin and means into the middle of
things or in the midst of things this
type of opening starts in the midst of
an important part of the story that is
presented out of order you won't truly
understand what's happening until the
details are filled in and you see what
led to the characters being where they
are Breaking Bad uses these cold opens
or pre-credit teasers as a way to hook
viewers in and plant lingering questions
that you want the answers to and in the
pilot episode in particular they do that
visually the question that it's asking
is who is this main character the khaki
pants are such a perfect way to bring us
to that question it's something that we
all recognize the sort of go-to choice
for something that's comfortable and
unthreatening but also not too casual
that you can't wear them to work here we
have this universally recognized thing
that is clearly not doing what it was
designed for they also become something
different hanging there like a floating
balloon before they come crash to the
ground as you're putting all this
together it's hard to miss how this is a
reflection of the character you're about
to meet the transition from tranquil
nature to chaos and this common object
that's completely out of place all must
be telling us something about this man
wearing tighty whitey underwear and a
gas mask you don't know why he's dressed
like that or where he's trying to go but
you get a sense that everything you're
being shown is part of a puzzle and that
if you can put it all together it will
make sense
there's another unknown character
wearing a gas mask passed out in the
passenger seat and too unconscious
possibly Dead characters sliding around
in the back in the middle of a mess that
includes broken glass money and some
kind of liquid sloshing around the first
answer comes after his Mass fogs up and
he crashes on the side of the road after
holding his breath to go back inside and
grab a gun and a video camera he starts
to leave a message for his family
despite all this Mayhem he seems to be a
family man and his name is Walter
Hartwell White and you can see that in
whatever he was trying to do things have
gone terribly wrong you have to wait to
get all the rest of the answers but you
can tell that this is a man who is as
out of place in this situation as his
pants were flying through the air as
Sirens approach it looks as though he's
prepared to meet his fate that he's able
to accept his situation but you can tell
that he never thought it would come to
this while Breaking Bad is innovative
and many anyways it's still built on a
solid foundation of what works best on
TB when asked what he learned about
writing from his time at the X-Files he
credited Chris Carter for teaching him
the idea of point of view especially
when dealing with suspense he says you
want to put the audience into the
Viewpoint of the character whose scene
it is and for a really great example
where he plays with this concept for
Laughs by showing Mulder and Scully
giving contrasting accounts of something
they experience through each of their
points of view check out the season 5
episode Bad Blood even though he
primarily wrote the episodic monster of
the week installments there he had one
significant change in mind for Breaking
Bad he wanted his main character to
change over the course of the series you
probably heard his much repeated sound
bite of turning Mr Chips into Scarface
which I guess you get bonus points if
you knew who Mr Chips was the first time
you heard that but essentially they
wanted to turn the protagonist who in
this case is an anti-here hero who
you're rooting for into a villain and
this could also be influenced by his
time working on the X-Files because that
show ran into a problem in that it
encouraged viewers to invest in a larger
Arc that it couldn't really resolve
without bringing the show to an end fans
got enthralled but never got to
satisfying payoff they imagined and most
of them just lost interest in the series
as it continued through a seemingly
inconsequential statement from the main
character to his students Gilligan lays
out his intentions for the entire series
when Walt asked them what chemistry is
he says he likes to think of it as the
study of change its growth then Decay
then transformation and he ends by
saying that it's fascinating really this
average and almost forgettable teacher
is telling us what's about to happen in
a way that will only be able to
understand after that transformation is
well underway because television at that
time wasn't something you could watch On
Demand like you can and now was
streaming most shows stuck to having
characters that didn't fundamentally
change the idea was that you could tune
into a show and know what to expect even
if you missed a few episodes or even a
whole season this meant that shows were
essentially designed to keep going until
people lost interest commercially that
might make some sense but creatively
it's a nightmare in today's TV landscape
using the run-up episodes to transform a
character seems like a no-brainer it's
the way that most shows are now
structured but when Gilligan was
pitching his idea it was a risky
proposition by all accounts it probably
wouldn't have been made if AMC wasn't
new to scripted TV and liked the script
so much that they were willing to take a
chance and let him realize his vision
with a pretty hands-off approach in the
end it worked out because it made it
perfect for binging by the time Netflix
came along and made the first three
seasons available for streaming
who the hell are you
with the Breaking Bad pilot does better
than anything else that came before it
is it introduces its main character
Walter White I don't think it's an
overstatement to say it does this
perfectly you know
you all know exactly who I am
the first two Acts were about 20 minutes
of the episode we learn most of what we
need to know about what kind of human
being he is and his motivations we go
back three weeks before the teaser and
his crisis in the RV to the morning of
his 50th birthday it was implied that
he's a family man and we meet him where
he lives it's a normal house in an
average neighborhood to quote the
original script Vince Gilligan described
it like this no president ever slept
here no millionaire ever visited this is
a three-bedroom rancher in a modest
neighborhood weekend trips to Home Depot
keep it looking tidy but it'll never
make the cover of architectural digest
as with his house there isn't much
that's remarkable about Walter his
wife's pregnant with the surprise baby
so even though they seem to have settled
into a marriage that isn't exactly spicy
they are at the very least intimate
sometimes his son Walter Jr has cerebral
palsy which could have been a challenge
but he seems to be well adjusted and
otherwise is a typical teenager there
are several indications that money's
tight but they're not on the verge of
losing the house or flat out broke some
of what we see here could hint that his
wife is controlling but most of that
doesn't hold up when you get more
information more than anything it seems
like he's somewhat passive and generally
disinterested I think one of the best
ways it shows us this is through his sad
little stair climber nothing says I've
let myself go more than a desperate
purchase of some exercise equipment that
might magically get you back on track
it's described in the script like this
it's well balanced on a Lillian Vernon
stair stepper just three easy payments
of 29.95 Walt plods up and down in the
darkness like he's marching to Baton
Brian Cranston does an incredible job of
bringing this character to life
throughout the episode but the way he
drops his head after seeing the one
thing that stands out from all this
mediocrity screams that there might be
something else there while he's on the
stair climber you see him look at a
plaque that's hanging on the wall which
is a recognition for being the project
leader on a project that contributed to
research awarded the Nobel Prize that
sounds pretty impressive so does it mean
that he's brilliant because none of what
we're seeing seems to reflect that all
the ingredients for a midlife crisis are
there but he doesn't seem like the type
of guy who could follow through with one
at this point still after the teaser you
know something is coming and after you
watch him at school where his students
don't appear to be interested and that
his demoralizing second job at the car
wash where he is embarrassed when he has
to clean one of their cars and at his
surprise birthday party where his
thickest cop brother-in-law is the
center of attention you get to what his
inciting incident is after passing out
at work he's taken to the hospital where
he finds out he's dying of cancer this
is a fairly straightforward way to take
him from being mostly a slob to someone
that you feel sorry for as far as you
can tell he's done nothing to bring this
on himself as he's trying to get the EMT
to drop him off at a corner somewhere
because he's worried about the bill he
might get due to his bad insurance he
tells him that he's never been a smoker
he's middle age which is way too young
to die but that's exactly what's
happening this is where Gilligan and
crew make an important choice in how
they deliver this scene it would be a
really easy place for them to hit an
emotional note and make us sympathize
with Walt in his sad situation a classic
scene like this might play out with the
swelling score that sets you up to get
emotional when you see Brian Cranston do
the same thing instead they withhold
that Outburst of emotion it's not
because he's incapable of emotion we've
already seen him cry while he was making
his goodbye video to his family it's not
because we don't know what he's
experiencing because they actually show
us that directly through a point of view
shot in that we see that he's staring at
the doctor's mouth and then focuses in
on a mustard stain on his jacket when it
cuts back to his face it looks like he's
lost he's confused he can't process what
he's hearing even though he can matter
of factly repeat the doctor's words back
to him lung cancer inoperable best case
scenario with chemo I'll maybe live a
couple more years this has been
definitely set up and is connected to
what Gilligan said about point of view
if you think back to everything you've
seen from seeing the 50 made out of
Veggie bacon which while Junior pointed
out smells like Band-Aids to the
birthday party where everyone is focused
on Hank instead of Walt to the shot
where he looks up to see Chad snapping
the picture of him cleaning his cool car
to the sad hand job where his wife is
distracted by her eBay auction through
his point of view all of these things
could feel like injustices and even if
he wouldn't fight for himself you might
feel like fighting for him my one
criticism of the pilot would be that
none of the other characters are close
to as interesting as Walt and even can
be uninteresting in the case of Hank and
Jesse but it makes sense if I think
about this being how Walt sees them and
even if you don't agree with that it's
forgivable since they promptly developed
them into complicated characters in The
Following episodes in the doctor's
office where he's confronted with a real
Injustice where for all intents and
purposes his life is over and much too
soon at that moment he doesn't know how
to react and that's a very human
response the choice to have it play out
that way takes him from being just
sympathetic or even pathetic if you
prefer and makes you empathize with him
I don't know what it's like to find out
I have cancer thankfully but I do know
what it's like to find myself in a
situation where I've just learned
something and I have no idea what to do
with the information the scene has
always stood out to me including the
first time I watched that because it
made me so much more invested in this
character in a way that I wasn't
expecting by the time he changes the
subject and points out the mustard stain
I was actively rooting for this guy
which turns out to be really important
because of what he does with this
information and where the creators are
planning on taking him from here going
back to watch it again you pick up on so
much that contributes to just how
effective it is and it can even help you
understand why you might have found
yourself wanting this guy to win longer
than you probably should have as most of
us did it cuts from the EMT listening to
his lungs in the back of the ambulance
to an overhead shot of him on this table
getting the scan where there's all these
strange noises that go along with that
to his reflection in the doctor's desk
then up to his bewildered expression
with a different ringing sound that
makes it impossible to hear what the
doctor is saying it almost feels unreal
which is exactly how Walt is processing
his diagnosis there was some indication
that he was sick but this is all
happening so fast that his mind can't
catch up and we're right there with him
everything in the first half of this
episode makes him relatable and that
gets you on his side and it's kind of
amazing how in this short amount of time
we bonded with him and are entirely on
board to root for him to the point that
it'll be hard to stop in some ways you
barely know him you get a brief glimpse
of his passion for chemistry when he's
talking to his students and then later
when he's showing Jesse the glassware he
stole from the high school you've seen
the plaque hinting that there might be
some sort of Genius but don't actually
see that he's competent until Jesse
declares him an artist after the first
cook and apart from the fact that he
thinks he can solve his problem by
navigating the criminal underworld
there's not much to indicate an inflated
sense of self this is a show about
change we witness him transform over the
course of the series into Heisenberg and
you see an incredible character Arc in
the 58 minutes of the pilot and crucial
we understand why he does the things he
does in this episode because they go to
such lengths to show us where he's
starting middle-aged man supporting a
family working two low-paying jobs
obviously not glamorous but apparently a
good person doing what he has to do to
take care of his family at the same time
it shows us what's missing what he's
missing in his life and then we get the
inciting incident that propels him to
break bad a death sentence there's a
point where Marie asks Skyler if Walt is
experiencing a midlife crisis which is a
good guess since that's the way it looks
from the outside but it's actually an
end of life crisis and we're in on the
secret since no one else knows about it
yet when change follows that and he
makes that absurd choice to make some
easy money manufacturing drugs in a way
that surely no one will ever get hurt
we're primed to overlook it when he
starts his partnership with Jesse by
threatening his freedom right from the
start you barely notice and are way more
likely to remember the humor that they
smartly used to temper the darkness
throughout the series everyone remembers
the cow house but the beginning of
Walt's descent feels more like the
Fallout from a bad decision instead of
feeling like we're watching a person
Embrace their darker side it's not a
decision you would make but you can
understand his motivation and you not
only believe that he's doing it for his
family but also that he believes that
too even when he attacks the teenagers
you think no one should really be doing
something like that but in this case
they definitely deserved it even when he
uses his chemistry skills to kill and
especially when he takes control on that
closing scene with Skyler it all starts
to feel like a victory there's a
difference between an anti-hero and a
villain he is an anti-hero at the end of
this episode but not yet a full-blown
villain the seeds are there they're
planted so we'll be able to go back and
see them in hindsight but they go by
unnoticed and that's the genius of the
writing and especially the acting on
Brian cranston's part in this episode we
understand why he does things even
though we wouldn't do them ourselves and
we're invested in wanting to see him win
and that's why it still rules even after
all these years it's a self-contained
story that shows change and delivers
resolution that also serves as a
compacted version of the larger story
we're about to watch play out over the
next 61 episodes please like this video
If you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and check
out my new Breaking Bad re-watch podcast
growth Decay transformation with
Courtney from Courtney's reviews you can
find links for that in the video
description to listen to us on
baldmove.com or wherever you listen to
podcasts thanks for watching I'll talk
to you soon